[Music]
selena gomez is getting candid about
growing up in the entertainment industry
and says she felt pressure to be overtly
sexual in her music videos i want a
boyfriend
the 28 year old singer covers the
october issue of allure and
reveals how her breakout role on disney
channel's wizards of waverly place
affected her day-to-day life
the same thing i always do entertaining
myself when the entertainment is not
entertaining me
quote my personal life was out
everywhere it felt
very claustrophobic and i felt very
trapped
selena says the media dissected
everything from her dating life to her
weight
something the singer describes as unfair
for someone to handle
miss russo even though you're frozen
i can see you
what about now after wizards came to an
end in 2012
selena turned her focus to her music
releasing her debut album stars dance in
2013
and revival in 2015.
and now selena is sharing that she felt
a demand to be
overly sexual in some of the music
videos quote there was pressure to see
more adults on my album revival i felt
the need to show skin
i really don't think i was that person
can't keep my hands to myself and
despite the challenges of fame that came
with her disney stardom
selena says she's grateful for how she
got her start
i just feel really blessed to have this
opportunity and she's learned to protect
herself
by never googling her name quote i
haven't done that in years i honestly
can't
i'm strong in a lot of ways but i think
i just have way too much of a sensitive
heart
now often times when selena uses her
platform
it's for a cause like mental health back
in april
selena revealed she was diagnosed with
bipolar disorder
after years of going through a lot of
different things
i realized that i was bipolar the triple
threat explained why her diagnosis was
empowering quote once i did find out
more about who i was
i was proud i also felt comfortable
knowing that i wasn't alone and i was
going to get through it
so i will always be passionate about
that it's something i will continue to
talk about
and all that echoes what selena told et
in 2017
i think that for me i'm really big on
vulnerability
i think people are really scared to to
be honest with themselves and
strength is looked upon as oh i'm strong
i don't need anything i can't
i can handle everything and that's just
not the truth i want people to know that
every
every single life is valuable and that
there are people who are willing to be
there for them